okay first of all talk fashion to me
because we've gone monochromatic this is
spring what is this
i mean this is rich fresh this is my guy
i wear him pretty exclusively at this
point
he just likes to play with colors you
know he knows what to do
i trust him completely and it's a good
it's always a good vibe you know we
wanted to we're coming outside for the
first time so
we decided to clean it up a bit i was
gonna ask how does it feel to be on a
red carpet at an awards show and get to
know how you're gonna look and get
dressed up i mean it's like weird
it's a strange feeling to get out of
sweatpants and put on actual pants
but it also feels good this is sort of
nice to see people there's all this sort
of this like euphoria in the air
because we've been at our houses for so
long anybody you're excited to see we
got dj khaled pink
oh my god you know i just watched pink's
documentary last night on amazon and i
was thoroughly impressed
so i'm excited to see pink because of
that but always her you know i just i
just walked past the migos which was
always a fun experience
there's just so much good music out
there is drake performing what's
happening he like getting an award
he owns the billboards there's nobody on
the billboards with drake
i love how you just gave pink some
support that was so nice like watch that
documentary
yo the daca is good man she's taking
care of her kids she's like working out
it's crazy
now speaking of music you're starting
your own label well here's the deal
i'm like i'm stepping in with def jam
dev jam has given us some space
and some money to bring in some artists
bring artist development back
and try to you know make some music
introduce some new musicians to the
culture we're excited
what kind of artists do you want to
bring to the forefront you know folks
that will be around for a long time i
think that to me is what's exciting like
i've been able to follow
you know some careers like i remember
erica baidu first dropped i remember
watching brandy's first music video
you know what i mean i remember hearing
whitney houston's song on the radio
greatest love of all
and then i got to literally watch their
careers like flourish and so my hope is
to introduce some
new artists that become you know classic
can you tease for us anybody who you've
signed
um i can't but there is someone that we
sign
and you know she's amazing she's out of
atlanta she's r b
she's dope stay tuned okay so tonight
are you like hey you need to collab with
my girl like
working for her you know what they're
going to want to collab i'm not going to
have to go follow them they're going to
be calling me they're going to lena how
do i get a feature i'm going to be like
look
we'll talk about it okay give us a
discount we'll see what happens
make a deal now the chai what can you
tell us about what we can expect next
yo the shy this season is just like a
whole new level
you know we got a whole new producing
director her name is ganja we got candy
burris is back we got
luke james is in the building lala
anthony is here
it's just a phenomenal season i think it
looks amazing we've been hearing from
people because we dropped episode early
and folks have been happy man you know
because folks are very
vocal if they do not like something okay
but they've been really vocal about how
much they enjoyed the first episode of
the show so
hopefully they feel that way about the
whole season it's going to be a wild
ride they are vocal
they're vocal man how do you handle the
vocals you know i usually don't say
anything back
because they always go in but i just try
to you know keep making art keep putting
stuff
out and they hopefully they just keep
tuning in and by the way candy i mean
that's somebody who's been in the
industry a long time so when you said
i'm going to get into music did you did
you call candy burris at all
what i should have called candy candy is
so great because candy and i are born on
the same day
we're birthday twins may 17th taurus
season just wrapped up
but you know she i have so much to learn
from her she's been in the game for a
long time she's a businesswoman
she does not play um and she's just fun
to be around but like honestly i should
ask her some questions i'ma set a zoom
you know for this week stay tuned candy
talk to me
you